HAVE A BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HEARING. ON K. TWELVE ISSUES
THAT WE DID NOT FINISH- TWO
WEEKS AGO- AND- SO TODAY WE
HAVE SOME MISCELLANEOUS
PROPOSALS FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
BUDGET RELATING COMMITTEE
SCHOOLS MEDICAL BILLING
STATEMENTS TO HELP SCHOOL
CLIMATE DATA AND THE
COLLABORATION FOR EDUCATION
ACCESS LISTEN COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE WELL THAT'S A
MOUTHFUL. AND I WISH WE HAD
SOME GREAT NEWS TO REPORT ABOUT
OUR SCHOOLS RE OPENING BUT- I'M
FEELING OPTIMISTIC- MORE AND
MORE VACCINES ARE BEING
DISTRIBUTED AROUND. CALIFORNIA
JUST THAT TODAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID A PRELIMINARY
GREENLIGHTED JOHNSON JOHNSON
THE THIRD VACCINE SO THAT
SHOULD BE HAVING THE FINAL
ACTION LATER THIS WEEK AND
THERE'S- MILLIONS ARE A
DELIBERATE CROSS CALIFORNIA AND
TWENTY MILLION. MILLIONS ACROSS
THE STATE THE NATION AND TWENTY
MILLION BY THE END OF MARCH
THEY SAID FOR JOHNSON AND
JOHNSON. AND THEN YOU KNOW THE
COUNCIL JUST GOING DOWN. THE
CROSS THAT THE STATE ANYWAY SO
HOPEFULLY WE AS A LEGISLATURE
CAN VOTE TO. MAKE IT EVEN
EASIER FOR DISTRICTS TO RICK TO
RE OPEN AND THAT PROVIDE MORE
RESOURCES FOR THEIR RE OPENING
AND LEARNING LOSS SO THAT'S OUR
CONTINUED ISSUE WE'RE TRYING TO
FOCUS ON BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE
HAVE A BUDGET TO. RECONCILE SO
WE'LL GO THROUGH THOSE THOSE
ISSUES THAT TODAY SO- WITH THAT
WE HAVE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND THE L. A. L. CORRECT. YEAH
YEAH. YEAH AND OF COURSE THIS
IS AT OUR PREPARED REMARKS FOR
THIS. PUBLICLY DISTANCE ARE A
PUBLIC NOTICE FOR AT THAT
SOCIALLY DISTANCE- COMMITTEE
ROOM TODAY WE'RE IN ROOM FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN- WE'RE A LARGE-
AND OF ROOM FOR SOME PUBLIC
COMMENTS TO MANY PEOPLE BECAUSE
PARTICIPATING HERE JUST YET
WILL HAVE ONE MINUTE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END. AND WILL
HAVE A CALL THE NUMBER THAT YOU
CAN- ENGAGE WITH AS WELL THAT
WILL BE- PRESENTED ON THE
SCREEN OUT AS WELL AS ALL READ
IT LATER IN THE AFTERNOON. SO
WITH THAT LET'S PROCEED WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS LIZ
MY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
THE UDGET PROVIDES TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND CHECK SPENT ON THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL PARTNERSHIP
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT. TO
HOLISTICALLY ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN. SO
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS OFFER A
UNIQUE MODEL TO MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
PROVIDE INTEGRATED EDUCATIONAL.
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO STUDENTS- WITH A
WIDE RANGE OF NEEDS. SO TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE IS VERY SIMILAR
TO EXISTING LANGUAGE AROUND THE
PROGRAM- BUT THE KITCHEN THAT
FUNDS WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
NEW COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. AS WELL
AS EXPANDING AND ENHANCING.
EXISTING COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. SO
COMMUNITIES GRANTS WOULD
SUPPORT LOCAL PARTNERSHIPS TO
IMPLEMENT THE PILLARS OF THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODEL WHICH
ARE PROVIDING INTENSIVE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES OFFERING
EXTENDED LEARNING TIME IN
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
DEVELOPING COLLABORATIVE
LEADERSHIP AND SUPPORT FOR
EDUCATORS AND OFFERING SUPPORT
FOR FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT- ADDITIONALLY UP 21%
OF THE ALLOCATION TO ME YEARS
FOR PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS WHO WANT TO EXPAND OR
ESTABLISH THEIR OWN COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS. SO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU L. L.
MORNING TURN MEMBERS MICHAEL
OFFICE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. WE WANTED TO
SHARE OUR THREE CONCERNS AN
ASSOCIATE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MODIFY THE PROPOSAL. OUR FIRST
CONCERN IS RELATED TO THE STATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS. RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT COMMUNITIES SCHOOLS
TEND TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH
POSITIVE STUDENT ESCORT
OUTCOMES HOWEVER SUCCESSFUL
ADOPTION REQUIRES FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGES THAT CAN BE COMPLICATED
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IMPLEMENT.
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITHOUT PRIOR
EXPERIENCE OPERATING COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS MAYBE HELP LEARNING HOW
TO DEVELOP EXTERNAL
PARTNERSHIPS COLLABORATE WITH
OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES. HI I'M
GOING A NEW STREAMS TO
IMPLEMENT AND SUSTAIN IT NEEDS
BECAUSE MODEL. TRANSLATION IS
NOT SPECIFY HOW THE STATE WILL
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND YOU KNOW THE FIRST ROUND OF
GRANTS PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. WE'RE IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. PARTNER STANDING IS A
CVS IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A PLAN FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WITH PROVIDERS FOR
THE FIRST TIME TO GRANT.
HOWEVER SINCE THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE SECOND UNDERGRADS INCLUDES
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THAT MAY BE
MORE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
EXISTING ONES. RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE SEPT SPECIFIC.
REQUIREMENTS FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AT A MINIMUM WE
RECOMMEND THE LET'S THE STATE.
OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BE
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST SCHOOLS
WITH CONDUCTING A COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENT. INCLUDING
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. CREATING
ANY PARTNERSHIPS AND DEVELOPING
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCES. WE
RECOMMEND ASSISTANCE BE
AVAILABLE FOR PROSPECT. OF THE
KINGS AND GRANT RECIPIENTS. OUR
THINKING CONCERN IS WITH THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. FOUR IN ORDER FOR
THE STATE TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS THE AS WAS MENTIONED BY
THE GOVERNOR FINANCED WITH THE
SUPPORT AND AMPLE EXTRACTION.
IF THEY WOULD HAVE 21% OF THE
FUNDING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO THE EXTENT THAT
SPECIFIC TO TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE REQUIREMENTS I
DISCUSS WOULD REQUIRE SPENDING
MORE THAN 1% OF THE TOTAL
GRANT. THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER INCREASING THE AMOUNT
THAT CAN BE SAID OF CYBER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. THE
PROPOSAL GRANT WILL PROVIDE
ABOUT TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION.
WHICH OPEN. FOR EACH YEAR OF
THE GRANT WITH IS ABOUT SOMEONE
HIGHER PART- SORRY RELATIVE TO
THE FIRST PRINT. TO ASSIST WITH
THAT MY OF FISH THE LEGISLATURE
COULD SCV FOR IN SPRING WITH
HIM OF TECHNICAL. AVAILABLE IN
THE CURRENT YEAR HAS BEEN
SUFFICIENT. TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THE FIRST FROM THE
GRANTEES. WOULD KNOW HOWEVER
THAT SINCE THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDES NEW COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
THERE WILL LIKELY BE MORE NEED
FOR SUBSTANTIAL. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE IN THE FIRST ROUND
OF GRANTS. ARE THERE CONCERNS.
WITH A JAIL LEGISLATION APPEARS
TO CLINTON COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AT
A DISADVANTAGE. THE PRIORITIES
LISTED IN THE CHAIR LANGUAGE.
FOR SELECTING GRANTEES IS THE
SAME AS THE FIRST FROM THE
GRANTS AND INCLUDES THINGS SUCH
AS HAVING COMMITTED MATCHING
FUNDS FOR PEOPLE SERVICES AND
HAVING A PLAN FOR SUSTAINING
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THIS IS DR
GRANT EXPLORATION. IS CRITERIA
PUT EXISTING COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
THAT ARE FARTHER ALONG AN
IMPLEMENTATION AT A
DISADVANTAGE OR NEW COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS TO ENSURE GRANTS ARE
AWARDED TO APPLICANTS
INTERESTED IN ESTABLISHING A
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE STRIP FUNDING INTO
TWO SEPARATE GRANTS. ONE FOR
EXPANDING EXISTING COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AND ONE FIRST
PUBLISHING COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
THIS PPROACH WOULD EXPAND THE
MODEL MORE EQUITABLY ACROSS THE
STATE AND SIR FUNDING CAN
BENEFIT COMMUNITIES THAT THE
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE THE CAPACITY
TO PROVIDE MORE COMPREHENSIVE.
SERVICES FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER PUSHING INTO
APPLICATION DEADLINE FOR THOSE
SEEKING TO ESTABLISH NEW
PROGRAMS TO LATER IN THE FISCAL
YEAR THIS WOULD GIVE ELEAZAR
MORE TIME TO SEE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS PRIOR TO
APPLICATION THAT ONE. OF THE
SECOND BECAUSE OUR COMMENTS
HAVE EVIDENCE. ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. YOU ALEXANDER ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE TO OF
PUBLIC AND- COMMITTEE SCHOOL
ARE ONE OF THE STATE'S
PRIORITIES AND HE HAS DONE A
GREAT DEAL OF WORK IN THIS AREA
BECAUSE COMMUNITY SCHOOL
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF THE WHOLE
CHILD WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INCLUDING MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE AND MANY
OTHER KEY SUPPORTS SCHOOLS CAN
YOU THIS INTEGRATED APPROACH TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO NURSES
COUNSELORS AND SOCIAL WORKERS.
TRADING PLACES WHERE CHILDREN
AND CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES
HAVE EASY ACCESS TO THE
SERVICES NEEDED TO HELP CLOSE
THE OPPORTUNITY GAP LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET INCLUDED FORTY FIVE
MILLION FOR CAL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM GRANT. THE CITY
RECEIVED A HUNDRED INTO APPLET
APPLICATIONS WITH A TOTAL ASK
OF A HUNDRED AND SIXTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION WHICH IS
NEARLY FOUR TIMES THE TOTAL
FUNDS ALLOTTED THE CDC WILL
ANNOUNCE CULINARY AWARDS
SHORTLY BUT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THE GRANT PROCESS WAS VERY
COMPETITIVE WITH A SCORE OF
EIGHTY NINE OUT OF A HUNDRED AT
THE CUT OFF FOR GRANTEES. THE
TOTAL THE TOTAL PERHAPS WILL GO
TO THE TOTAL GRANT FUNDS EXCUSE
ME WILL TO GRANT. AND THEN
INCLUDE BOTH CONSORTIA AND SAY
SCHOOL AT WITH THE WORDS FROM
HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
HUNDRED TO MILLION. IT IS. THAT
THE DEMAND FOR THESE. IF HIGHER.
THAN FUNDS THAT WERE A LOT LAST
YEAR. WE INTO THE THAT THE
DEMAND BE MUCH. ON THE GOVERNOR
SCRIPT. BECAUSE THE PRE ROUND
OF. WITHIN TO A- COMMUNITIES
FOR. WHICH IS NOT THE CASE THIS
NEW. WHEN COUPLED THE INCREASE
TIMELINE FOR USING THE FUNDS WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE WILL BE
EVEN GREATER DEMAND FOR THIS
NEW ROUND OF FUNDING. I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY PEAK CALLOUS AND
LISA REMMERS ACCOUNT AT THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER TRANSITIONS
DIVISION AT THE EASY ANSWER ANY
PROGRAMMATIC. QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU OKAY. WE'RE
GONNA SEE MISTER. I LIKED I
LIKED HIM IT JUST HELLO AND SEE
IF MY KIDS AND HAVE HIM HERE
AND THERE. SO SHOW YOUR FACE
MISTER. AMONG. WHAT IS THE
TOPIC FOR THAT INVOLVED ALL YOU
HAVE TO START YET IT'S A AY A
COUPLE WORDS IN A QUEUE UP YOUR
VIDEO. OKAY CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW. YEAH THERE YOU ARE I JUST
WANT TO SAY WELL. THEY CAN'T
EVEN KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OKAY. OKAY
SO I'M- I HAVEN'T THAT COUPLE
QUESTIONS I WANT TO ASK BUT
THEY ARE QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THE NUMBER
OF ITEMS. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION- HOW MANY OF
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODELS
FUNDED THROUGH THE HEALTHY
START INITIATIVE REMAIN
OPERATIONAL. SO DO WE HAVE CITY
AIRPORT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ANSWER THAT QUESTION DRESS
THESE ISSUES. SO I CAN START
AND I NEED TO ASK KEEP TO JUMP
IN AGAIN ALEXANDER FROM IT FROM
THE REPRESENTATIVES
SUPERINTENDENT THE CITY HAS NOT
ADMINISTER THE HEALTHY START
INITIATIVE SINCE NEED FIRST
TWENTY FIFTEEN SO IT'S GONNA
TAKE US SOMETIME TO RESEARCH
THE HEALTHY START PROGRAM WE
STARTED TO LOOK INTO THIS. BUT
IT WILL TAKE THE TIME TO REVIEW
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE- SO
UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT. AWARE OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING AT THIS TIME
I'D KEEP WE HAVE A CONTINUING
PROGRAM. HI I'M NOT SURE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE HOPE THE STORE
WASN'T PART OF OUR DIVISION
HILLS AND A DIFFERENT DIVISION
WITHIN CITY SO WE HAVE TO DO
SOME RESEARCH WE TRY TO DO SOME
RESEARCH LAST WEEK ON IT AND
MOST OF THE DATA NO LONGER
EXISTS ON OUR WEBSITE. AND YOU
THINK THAT THAT SAID SO
INITIALLY THERE WERE ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY THREE
PLANNING GRANTS AND- THE END OF
THESE GRANTS IT DID IN ADDITION
TO YOU KNOW SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
ONE OPERATIONAL NINETEEN
COMBINED GRANTS. SO I'M JUST
CURIOUS YOU KNOW IT THOSE OF
IMPACTED OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY SCHOOL SITES AND IT
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL AND
USEFUL- TO KNOW HOW MANY ARE
STILL IN EXISTENCE FROM EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE- MY NEXT
QUESTION IS AROUND THE ORIGINAL
AGAIN THE ORIGINAL HSA. AWARDS
THEY'RE FUNDED FOR BOTH
PLANNING AND OPERATIONAL GRANTS
IS THE ADMINISTRATION OPEN TO
DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN PLANNING
AND OPERATIONAL GRANTS AS WELL
AS PROVIDING SEPARATE
ALLOCATIONS FOR NEW COMMUNITY
SCHOOL EFFORTS. VERSES THOSE
PROPOSING TO EXPAND AN EXISTING
COMMUNITY SCHOOL AND I ASK THIS
BECAUSE I'M REALLY CURIOUS TO
KNOW IF THEY SHOULD BE- IF AND
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING FOR NEW
FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS ARE
LOOKING FOR NEW TWENTY SHOULD
REALLY BE IN THE SAME CATEGORY.
CATEGORY AS EXIST PROGRAM THAT
ARE ARE WE IMAGINE MUCH MORE
COME VERSUS A NEW START UP.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
AMORALITY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND WE'RE CERTAINLY
OPEN TO THAT CONVERSATION WE
DO- AGREE WITH A LOT OF VELLIOS
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS AREA.
AND I THINK THAT THE PEOPLE AND
SUPPORT ARTICLE FULL OF. I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT IT IN YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S START UP COSTS AS
WELL AS AND PUBLIC TYPICAL TOP
ACCESSING INFRASTRUCTURE IN
AREAS WHERE SCHOOLS DO
CURRENTLY EXIST. I'M CERTAINLY
OPEN TO TAXPAYERS GEN. THANK
YOU. FOR THE QUESTIONS I WANT
TO ASK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
RESPOND TO- THE L. A. L.
SUGGESTION AS FAR AS BREAKING
IT UP AND- PICKING MORE WINNERS
AS OPPOSED TO JUST YOU KNOW
HAVING WINNERS AND LOSERS AND I
DO REMEMBER THE- HEALTHY START
INITIATIVE IN THEIR SCHOOLS-
THEY WERE IN MY COMMUNITY WHEN
I WAS AT FRANKLY COUNCILMEMBER
FOR TEN FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. AND
IT WAS A IT WAS A IT WAS A
SUCCESS- A LOT OF ENRICHMENT
PROGRAMS THEREFORE NOT JUST IN
THAT STUDENTS AFTER SCHOOL BUT
THAT THE COMMUNITY AS A WHOLE
AND AFTER I THINK THAT
RECESSION IS WHEN THEY KIND OF
FIZZLED OUT SO I THE CONCEPT IS
A GOOD ONE AND YOU KNOW HAVING
MORE SEX. SCHOOLS NEIGHBORHOOD
SCHOOLS ACTIVELY ENGAGE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES SOMETHING WE
CAN ALL SUPPORT SO AT THE L. A.
L. SUGGESTION IT IS I THINK NOT
A BAD ONE SO WE CAN HELP MORE
IN THE PIPELINE- SO WHAT DOES
THE PERMANENT FINANCE HAVE TO
SAY ABOUT THAT. ALEXANDER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
THINK WE WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
AND THAT THE ONLY- SUGGESTION-
IN TERMS OF SPLITTING OUT AND
DOES MAKE SENSE AND- I THINK WE
WOULD. FURTHER CONVERT ST
ANNE'S RECOGNIZING- AS THE
PERMANENT EDUCATION POINT OUT
THAT. THERE WAS THE PRIVATE
COMING IN AND THERE WERE
APPLICATIONS THAT WERE
SUBMITTED NOT AROUND THAT WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO BE COMPLETED OR
FUNDED AT ALL. AND I KNOW IN
THE FIRST ROUND WE DID TARGET
I'M ONLY IF THE EXISTING
COMMUNITY SCHOOL SECOND WE WANT
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION IN TERMS
OF. HOW THOSE APPLICATIONS THAT
HAD DONE MAYBE NOT BEEN FUNDED-
WHAT MADE YOU GET. INTO THAT
PRIORITIZATION AS WELL. AND
THEN HAVE TO HOW THIS. FOR
UNDER. SO THIS IS. THE IN THE-
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET WAS ONE TIME
SO WHAT WHAT WHAT'S THE ONGOING
FINANCIAL COMMITMENT FOR THESE.
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS. AMBER
ALEXANDER AGAIN- WITH FINANCIAL
WE ARE PROPOSING ONE TIME
FUNDING AGAIN I THINK I'M MORE
INTERESTED IN THE CONVERSATIONS
AS WELL AROUND THE ON GOING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE STRUCTURE
AND THINK THAT THAT- YOU KNOW
THAT WILL CERTAINLY FACTOR IN
IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO
SUSTAIN THESE INVESTMENTS- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT YOU KNOW OUR
INTENTION IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
WILL CONTINUE TO LEVERAGE SOME
OF THE ON GOING RESOURCES AND
IN TERMS OF THE L. C. F. F. AND
TAKE CONTINUE THESE
INVESTMENTS- BUT YOUR POINT IS
NOTED- IN TERMS OF THE FACT
THAT WE ARE PROVIDING- ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THIS. PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAM AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK
YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SAYING
YEAH ONE MORE QUESTION SO
NUMBER VIOLATE US YET SO WHO IS
THE CITY PLANNING TO CONTRACT
WITH TO PROVIDE THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND COMPLETE THE
FINAL REPORT FOR THE FORTY FIVE
MILLION GRANT AWARDS AUTHORIZED
IN. THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
BUDGET ACT. I LIKE KERN AGAIN
WITH THAT. THE STATE RUN THAT
WE- NEED CONTACT WEST TO
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
DONE WITH ON. PART. THANK YOU.
OKAY YES I'M A MEMBER REYES SO
DOES THE DEPARTMENT ACACIA HAVE
THE TECHNICAL SYSTEM INTEREST
ALREADY- AND IF SO. THE- WHAT
IS IT TO- AND HOW WOULD THAT BE
EXPANDED. I WILL NEED TO DEFER
TO YOU PETE CALLOUS FROM CD FOR
FURTHER INFORMATION HERE. OKAY
SO THE CALCIUM CITY SO WE DO
NOT HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
THIS PROGRAM THAT'S WHY WE'RE
LOOKING AT CONTRACTING WITH-
WEST DEAD AND SOME OF THEIR-
SUPPORT THAT THEY HAVE FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU SEE
NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE- OPEN. AND PROCEED WITH
ISSUE NUMBER TWO SCHOOL MEDIC
CAL BILLICK. IT WAS MY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE MILLION
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO SELECT TWO OR
MORE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TO CONVENE PROFESSIONAL
NETWORKS AND DIFFERENT REGIONS
OF THE STATE- THAT WILL SUPPORT
ONLY AS AND SUCCESSFUL
PARTICIPATION IN THE LEN. ONLY
A MEDICAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM THEY ALSO IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES IN REGARDS TO MEDICAL
BILLING- FOR- AS A WHOLE AND
PROVIDE PEER TO PEER LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD CAPACITY
IN THIS AREA. IN ADDITION THE
BUDGET INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND AND
TO A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY
WITH DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS IN
SUBMITTING CLAIMS THROUGH THE
ALLEN A MEDICAL BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM AND OTHER MEDICAL
BILLING PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE IN BUILDING CAPACITY
AND SAID THIS IS AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN THIS AGENCY IT
WOULD WORK IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT. TO DISSEMINATE BEST
PRACTICES AND RESOURCES AS WELL
SERVE AS A POINT OF CONTACT FOR
OTHER EARLY EIGHTIES AND THIS
AGENCY WOULD ALSO PARTICIPATE
AND- MEDICAL BILLING WORK
GROUPS YEAH THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES. CAN
MEANS. AND SAID THIS- ADDRESS
OF THE- NEED AND BEING I DON'T.
BY THE S. B. C. FIVE GROUPS AND
I REMEMBER. SBRA THE NEED FOR
CAPACITY BUILDING AND TO FILL
KNOWLEDGE GAPS ABOUT THE
PROGRAMS AND THESE PROPOSALS
WILL ALSO PUT INFRASTRUCTURE IN
PLACE FOR ONE FINAL
RECOMMENDATIONSCOME OUT. HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
THANK YOU. NEXT PRESENTER.
ALAIA GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
AMY LEE WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THIS AFTERNOON
I WANTED TO PROVIDE SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE GOVERNOR'S
MEDICAL BILLING PROPOSALS
BEFORE SHARING OUR ASSESSMENT
AND RECOMMENDATION BRIEFLY BY
WAY OF BACKGROUND SCHOOLS HAVE
THE OPTION TO SEEK PARTIAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SOME HEALTH
RELATED SERVICES FROM MEDIC
HELL THROUGH THE SCHOOL BASED
MEDICAL BILLING PROGRAM COVERED
LOW PARTICIPATION HAS BEEN A
LONG STANDING ISSUE IN THE
PROGRAM AS ONLY ABOUT HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOL DISTRICTS
PARTICIPATE COVERING A VERY
SMALL SHARK SHARE OF K. TWELVE
STUDENTS STATE WIDE. IN
RESPONSE TO WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING IN THE PROGRAM IN
THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
PACKAGE PROVIDED FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO JOINTLY
CONVENED A WORKGROUP FOCUSED ON
MEDICAL BILLING THE WORK GROUP
IS TASKED WITH PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO IMPROVE ACCESS
AND PARTICIPATION AND THE
MEDICAL BILLING PROGRAM CHAMISA
CONDITIONS ARE DUE OUT BY
OCTOBER FIRST OF THIS YEAR THE
WORKERS INTERIM REPORT WAS
RELEASED IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
BARRIERS TO PROGRAM
PARTICIPATION INCLUDING A LACK
OF INTER AGENCY COLLABORATION
BETWEEN CD AND DH CS.
CHALLENGING DOCUMENTATION AND
BILLING SYSTEM REQUIREMENTS A
HIGH SURE CLEANS BEING
DISALLOWED AND LIMITED STATE
LIVE TRAINING AND SUPPORT
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS WHICH FINANCES
ALREADY DESCRIBED WE RECOGNIZE
THAT DISTRICTS NEED MORE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
SUPPORT TO SUCCESSFULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEDICAL
BILLING PROGRAM HOWEVER GIVEN
THAT THE MEDICAL BILLING
WORKGROUP WILL HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS OUT TO FURTHER
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IN OCTOBER
WE THINK THESE PROPOSALS ARE
RATHER PREMATURE FURTHERMORE-
THE GOT THE WORKERS INTERIM
REPORT HIGHLIGHTED A POTENTIAL
NEED FOR STATE LEVEL LEADERSHIP
WHICH MAY BETTER ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF SCHOOLS THEN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE WE ASSESSED THAT
MEDICAL BILLING PROPOSALS NEXT
YEAR FOR THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET PROCESS AFTER IT
HAS HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THE FINAL WORKGROUP
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CONCLUDES
OUR REMARKS. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THE OF A- OKAY- ALEXANDER
BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IN THE
STATE- STATE SUPERINTENDENT
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TALLY IS TO ACCESS
FEDERAL MEDICAL FUNDS THE S.
AND P. I. HAS PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED HOW MULTIPLE STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT ELEAZAR MISSING
OUT ON TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENTS. BUT WITHIN FOR
IMPORTANT UP ENFORCEMENT IS
ACTUALLY PROVIDING KIND OF
SERVICES ARE CHILDREN SO
DESPERATELY NEED MAN ISSUE THAT
IS MADE ALL ONLY BEEN MADE MORE
APPARENT AS THE AS THE PANDEMIC
CONTINUES ON ACCORDING TO
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
ONLY FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE ELEAZAR PARTICIPATED IN
THE MEDIC HOW BILLING PROGRAM
IN FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN. A NUMBER THAT HAS
INCREASED ONLY BY ONE ALLEY
EIGHT IN EACH YEAR SINCE FISCAL
YEAR TWELVE THIRTEEN OF THOSE
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE L. E.
EIGHT THANK THAT WAS AT LEAST
GOING TO HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION WHICH IS
THE DIGNITY CREASE OF NEARLY
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE
THAN 10% FROM THE HIGH POINT IN
FISCAL YEAR FOURTEEN FIFTEEN.
THESE NUMBERS SHOW THE NEED FOR
ACTION IN THE SPACE IS VERY
REAL THE PROPOSALS IN FRONT OF
YOU TODAY ARE ONE IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF THE SOLUTION HOWEVER
I WOULD NOTE THAT ADDITIONAL
WORK IS NEEDED INCLUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
INCENTIVIZE MEDI CAL PLANS TO
INVEST IN DELIVERING CRITICAL
SERVICES TO STUDENTS AS WELL AS
THE OTHER YEAH IT'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT AT THE STATE
LEVEL FOR LEDS EXPANDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE AND
EXPERIENCE TO ENSURE SUCCESSFUL
MEDICAL BILLING. THERE ARE ALSO
SOME OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
SUCH AS CRITERIA AND LED FLEX A
PROCESS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW BEST TO
PUT ALL OF THESE PIECES
TOGETHER SO THEIR CHILDREN GET
THE SERVICES THEY SO
DESPERATELY NEED WHILE ENSURING
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE BREAKING
THE BANK IN THE PROCESS. I HAVE
WITH ME SERRA NOVEL MORGAN
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT AT CDT
ANSWER ANY PROGRAMMATIC
QUESTIONS. YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. QUEST ARE CALM YOU CAN
MEMBERS. MISTER DONNA. WITH
REGARD TO THE MEDICAL BILLING
PROGRAM- SCHOOLS WOULD BE ABLE
TO BILL FOR I'M LOOKING FOR
HERE COUNSELING OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY SPEECH THERAPY AND
TRANSPORTATION SOME ABOUT HALF
THE SCHOOLS ALREADY. DO BILL
FOR THAT IS THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE. HASKELL DISTRICT
PROBABLY. IT COULD SOMEONE
RESPONDING. TO ALLIE GARNER
FROM CD WE UNDERSTAND THAT
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE ELEAZAR CURRENTLY UTILIZE
THE ALLEY A MEDICAL BILLING
PROCESS USES ABOUT HALF AND
THEY CAN'T BILL FOR I'M JUST
LOOKING INTO THE REASONS LISTED
IN. IN THE DOCUMENT I HAVE TO
COUNSELING OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
SPEECH THERAPY AND
TRANSPORTATION BUT NOT FOR
GENERAL HEALTH PURPOSES IS THAT
ACCURATE SO IF SOMEONE WAS
FEELING ILL THAT DAY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THAT WOULD
NOT BE AN ALLOWABLE. A
BILLABLE- SITUATION THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO BILL FOR THAT FOR
DRESSING THAT ISSUE AT A SCHOOL
SITE IS THAT ACCURATE.
UNFORTUNATELY I DON'T HAVE AN
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION THE
BILLABLE ANSWER IT THE LITTLE
QUESTION IS SOMETHING THAT I
BELIEVE IT IS THE MARK OF WHY
WE NEED THIS WORK HERE AND WHY
WE NEED STATE LEVEL SUPPORT
BECAUSE NEITHER CVS NOR DH CS
REALLY HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ANSWERS TO BE ABLE TO. PROVIDE
ANSWERS ABOUT WHAT DOES AND
DOESN'T HAPPEN DOES OR DOES NOT
HAPPEN. ON AN ALLEY A BUILDING
SITE. OKAY IMAGE I'M JUST I'M
TRYING TO GET A WHAT SERVICES
MIGHT BE OFFERED. AT LIKE A
HIGH SCHOOL RIGHT AS ONE WHO
TEACHES THE LARGEST HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE STATE. THIS IS
SOMETHING. THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
HAPPENING THERE. BUT THE TOWNS
OVER TO A DIFFERENT. I GET I
GET THAT QUESTION ANSWERED
LATER. BOB THE DEVOUT 50% OF
SCHOOL ADMITTED IT'S NOT
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM YOU
SIDE OF FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
NINE. SO THE INTENT IN THIS
THIS PROPOSAL IS THAT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE OTHERS TO DO IT IS
THAT IT. AMBER ALEXANDER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YES.
IT'S TO ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION
IN ONE OF THE THINGS WE'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM ELEAZAR- IS THAT
THE PROGRAM IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO NAVIGATE AND THAT THOSE WHO
DO- DO NAVIGATE THE PROGRAM
OFTEN FIND- FIND TROUBLE ON THE
BACK AND AFTER SUBMITTING
CLAIMS- IN TERMS OF NAVIGATING
THE AUDIT PROCESS SO THERE'S A
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPONENTS TO
THE PROGRAM THAT IT SEEMS LIKE
IT. I'M DH CS IT IS TRYING TO
ASSIST LEN ACTING BUT BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT THAT CONNECTION TO
THE EDUCATIONAL- EXCEPT- OVER
AT THE AGE S. THERE REALLY
NEEDS TO BE MARKED THAT- CARE
TO CARE L. EA- ELLIE EIGHT.
EIGHT AM. TYPE OF CAPACITY
BUILDING AND REALLY WHY ARE-
FROM THE MEASURE IS TRYING TO
GET BACK. THANK YOU. IN THIS IS
MY SEVENTH YEAR HERE AND I
THINK THAT SURE WOULD AGREE
WITH ME THIS IS A SEVENTY YEAR
WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE. SO
SOMETHING'S WRONG HERE. THAT WE
HAVE TO FIND. YOU KNOW WE HAVE
TO HOW DO WE HAVE TO SOMEHOW.
YOU KNOW GATHER SOME EXPERTS TO
GOING TO SCHOOLS THAT ARE DOING
IT WHY CAN'T I JUST DON'T HOW
HARD CAN IT BE OR WHO'S MAKING
IT SO HARD AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS MAKING IT SO
DIFFICULT. OR IS THE STATE. THE
LOGISTICS WITH APPLYING TO THE
STATE PROGRAM THE STATE MEDICAL
BILLING SYSTEM. MORE DOUBLE I
MEAN WONDERING IS THE PROBLEM
WITH THE SCHOOL AND MAYBE. IT
OR IS THE PROBLEM WITH THE
BILLING SYSTEM. MAYBE WE NEED
TO INSTEAD OF. WORRY ABOUT THE
SCHOOLS MANY WORRY ABOUT HOW WE
APPROACH THE BUILDING FROM THE
SCHOOL SITES DID YOU HAVE AN
ANSWER TO THAT. SO MAYBE
FINANCE. AMBER ALEXANDER- AGAIN
WITH THE PERSONAL FINANCE-
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS
THIS PROPOSAL BUT THAT
MINISTRATIONS SUPPORT IS REALLY
JUST ONE PIECE RECOGNIZING
THAT- THE SQ SEVENTY FIVE
WORKGROUP IS REALLY- CURRENTLY
DELVING INTO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND
PROGRAMMATIC. REFORM THAT MAY
NEED TO BE- MAKE MAY NEED TO BE
IMPLEMENTED- AROUND L. A. BACH
PROGRAM I'M I MEAN ABOUT THAT
DH CS AND ALSO LOOKING AT THEM.
C. D. E. AND THEIR NEEDS AND
HOW THEY CAN ASSIST IN THIS
AREA SO THIS IS THIS IS ONE
PIECE THIS IS DEFINITELY NOT
GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM- BUT
I THINK YOU KNOW IT'S AN IN
RECOGNITION OF THE FACT THAT
HOPEFULLY NETWORK GROUP AND
WHEN THEY RELEASED THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN OCTOBER.
WE'LL GET MORE OF THOSE ISSUES
THAT YOU'RE- BRINGING UP AS
WELL AS MOVEMENT-O'DONNELL.
OKAY THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR RESPONSES I JUST. I
THINK THERE'S MORE HERE THAN I
THINK THE PROBLEM HERE IS MOE
THAN MONEY- YEAH YEAH THAT'S
KNOWLEDGE. IT'S THE TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE ON THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND- BUT IF IT'S SO
DIFFICULT TO DO THAT HALF OF
THEM AR DOING IT I THINK
THERE'S ANOTHER PROBLEM HERE TO
WHICH I THINK YOU MAY YOU MAY
HAVE A KNOWLEDGE- SO. I JUST
HOPE THAT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THIS. IN ANOTHER A- MY
BECAUSE I'M WORRIED THAT WE
WILL IT SEEMS LIKE. WE'VE
CREATED OUR OWN PROBLEM WE'VE
CREATED OUR OWN WALL HERE. THAT
WE CAN NOW JUMP OVER. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSES.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EXACTLY THAT'S THEIR NUMBER
MORE AGAIN CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO I'M
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE LANDS ON
THE WORK GREAT AND I. FEEL THE
BEST WHAT DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES. I AM IN NO WAY
AND MEDICARE BILLING EXPERT BUT
WE ARE IN- IN THESE MEETINGS AT
LEAST EVERY OTHER WEEK OR FIVE
SERVICE THAT. PART THAT'S BEEN
RAISED BY THE MAJORITY OF THE
EIGHTH AS THAT MAJOR PAIN
POINTS. LATE IN THE BILLING
PROCESS. AUDITING COMPONENT
THAT. A CEMENT BELLS AND IT CAN
UP TO A FOR THEM TO GO
SOMETHING THAT NOT. AND THEN
THEY HAVE NO WAY TO RECOUP THIS
COST. THAT WE HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION IN THAT PENDING.
THERE ARE MERGING
RECOMMENDATION COMPONENT THAT
WOULD DEEPLY INVESTIGATE THAT
PROCESS AND MAKE CHANGES TO
SHORTEN THE TIME PERIOD AROUNDS
THE AUDIT TEAM SAID THE ALLEY.
CAN MORE EFFECTIVELY. THEY ALSO.
NEED TO BE. IN WHAT HOW CLEAR
IT IS WHAT'S- TO REALLY AT
LEAST WITH THAT. BUT WE REALLY
ELEVATED THE PROCEED TO HAVE
STRONGER CAPACITY IN THIS AREA
AS WELL AS HAVE. HEALTHCARE
SERVICES I UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT LONGER. THANK MARK THANK
YOU LISTEN I DON'T THINK YOU
NEED TO HAVE A DOCTORATE
ACCOUNTING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BILL. ESPECIALLY FROM THE L. E.
A. LEVEL THIS MUST BE IS HAS TO
BE. MADE TO BE A SIMPLER
PROCESS- SO I. I HOPE WE CAN
FIX THIS BECAUSE THIS SEEMS TO
ME LIKE WE'VE CREATED OUR OWN
PROBLEM AND ARE RUNNING AROUND
IN CIRCLES. AND I'M SURE
SOMEONE OTHER THAN A HIGH KNOWS
THE ANSWER TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM AND IT'S PROBABLY INTO
PLACE IS PROBABLY THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT LEVEL YES. DEVELOPING
AN EXPERTISE ON THE BUSINESS
SIDE OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE
ALSO THAT YOU KNOW. HOW THE IF
IT'S SO DIFFICULT. TO APPLY FOR
REIMBURSEMENT. THAT THAT THAT
THAT'S THAT'S QUITE A HURDLE
TOO MANY LOOK AT THAT PROCESS
WHICH IT SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE
DOING SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VIA NOTICES.
I'M SO IF THE INTERAGENCY
WORKGROUPS FINAL REPORT IS DUE
ON OCTOBER FIRST WHY WHY NOT
WAIT AND FOR THE MOVING FORWARD
WITH THIS NOVEL I MEAN
WOULDN'T. THAT POTENTIALLY
CREATE A FALSE START OR EVEN
MORE CONFUSION FOR ELEAZAR. IF
I MAY I LIKE HONOR ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT TOOK PLACE LAST YEAR WAS
THAT THERE'S A STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT THAT THE PLANET
AMENDMENT ALLOWS FOR RETRACTED
BILLING PRESS THE FIVE YEARS.
THAT CLOCK STARTED LAST JULY
AND SO THE LONGER WE WAIT THE
LONGER SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BACK AND
RETROACTIVELY BELL. SO WE CAN
START BUILDING SOME OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ROUTES TO
THE FINALIZATION OF THIS SB
SEVENTY FIVE REPORT I THINK
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE AHEAD ON
THAT CAPACITY. SO IS THIS. DOES
THIS PROPOSAL REFLECTS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. YOU KNOW-
GOAL OF USING. PROP NINETY
EIGHT RESOURCES TO SUPPORT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROBABLY A
MEDICAL BILLING RATHER THAN
FEDERAL FUNDS OR NON PROP
NINETY. RESOURCES. AMBER
ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WORK WE'RE CERTAINLY
OPEN TO- CONVERSATION AROUND. I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE AT A
FEDERAL FUNDING SOURCE THAT MAY
BE MORE APPROPRIATE AT THIS
POINT AND THE ADMINISTRATION
PUT FORWARD I'M PROP
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING- ONE BECAUSE WE HAVE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE AND TO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE- PUT
OUT A STRONG SIGNAL THAT THIS
IS AN AREA THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IT'S- CARRIED
DEEPLY ABOUT AND WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE SOME
MONEY THAT WE WERE ABLE TO PUT
ON THE TABLE WELL. FIRST BUDGET
TO ENSURE THAT. THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ON THIS JUST THE OBVIOUS THAT
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS THE KIDS WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND-
HE SUPPORT LEAVING MONEY ON THE
TABLE. THAT'S EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING AND IT'S
FRUSTRATING THAT WE FREE
ASISTIR TAL SAID. WE CAN'T
FIGURE OUT- THIS A YOU KNOW
PART OF ME WANTS TO KNOW WHY
WE'RE NOT HERE WITH. OUR
HEALTHCARE SITE TO DIFFERENT
FROM THAT THAT PERSPECTIVE.
IT'S HARD TO FIGURE OUT- DAY
THE K. TWELVE SIDE OF THIS
THING START HAVING SOME
EXPERTISE FROM THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL AS WELL SO MISTER TRICK
AND I JUST COMMON YET MR THAT
IT WAS SO IS DH CS IS THAT
DEPARTMENT HEALTHCARE SERVICES
THAT WITH INSTANCE WERE.%
CORRECT BECAUSE I HEAR THERE
THE PROBLEMS THEY'RE AUDITING
CREW THAT COMES IN HERE AND
CREATES A LOT OF PROBLEMS FOR
DISTRICTS SO WHY ISN'T- YOU
KNOW. WHAT WHILE SOME OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH BLOWING THEM
UP SO THIS CAN GET FIXED. I
MEAN THIS SEEMS TO BE LIKE
WE'RE CREATING THIS LONG PATH
TO FIND A SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM
WE ALREADY KNOW THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT SO I THINK WE KNOW THE
SOLUTION. AND SO I MAYBE
PERSONNEL WISE SO I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THIS AND ARGUING OVER
BUDGETS IN EXCESS. THIS SHOULD
BE FIXED. SEVEN YEARS AGO
EASILY. OKAY POINT MADE WE WILL
HOLD THIS ISSUE OPEN- THE NEXT
ISSUE NUMBER THREE STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ALL BUT IF YOU'RE PAYING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
SCHOOLS ARE CRITICAL POINT OF
ACCESS FOR PREVENTATIVE AND
EARLY INTERVENTION BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. ARMILLARY DATA ALSO
SUGGESTS THAT DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY MAY HAVE TO INCREASE
THE PROTRACTOR IN THE PADDOCK.
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH CHALLENGES AND
PROMOTE WELLNESS GOALS THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
SEVERAL INITIATIVES AIMED TO
INCREASE RESOURCES AND
COORDINATE EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
I'LL GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF OUR
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE PROVIDE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MATCHING FUNDS FOR CLOSING THE
HEALTH. THE PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT
CHILDREN'S MNTAL HEALTH THANK
MANY DISCUSS THE SERVICES
AVAILABLE AND FOR FIGHTING I'M
EVERYTHING REPORTERS DISTRICT
IN THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
ELEAZAR COUNTY. THE FUNDING
MIGHT RECOGNIZE THE HEALTH
NEEDS TO KEEP YOUR CALL IT AN
IN A MANNER CONSISTENT WITH A
WHOLE CHILD APPROACH. AND
SUPPORT ACTIVITIES SUCH AS THE
DEVELOPMENT OF PRECOURT
NETWORK. SUPPORT FOR FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT. AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR EDUCATORS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TWENTY FIVE
MILLION ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANT. THAT WOULD
PROVIDE A ONE DOLLAR PROP
NINETY EIGHT MATCH PROBABLY ONE
DOLLAR A FUNDING AND COUNTIES
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
THREE YEAR SPENDING PLAN THAT
IS DEDICATED TO A PROJECT THAT
SUPPORTS CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND SCHOOL. I
LEAVE BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
THE FUNDING AND WE WORK WITH
THE COUNTY PARTNERED ON A
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND TALK ABOUT
THE WHOLE PROJECT. WITHIN THE
COUNTY FOR YOUR SPENDING PLAN
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES FOR
SETTING. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
OFFERING TWO ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH PROPOSALS. THE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
I MEET AT THE STATE PARTNERSHIP
RANT THAT WOULD SUPPORT THE
EXISTING PROGRAM. WITH PROGRAMS
AND PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
BALK AND ADDRESSING THROUGH
FIGHTING SHOPPACH EVENTUALLY
SERVICES. OUTREACH HIGHER YOU
AND OTHER STRATEGIES THAT
REFLECT THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
THE SECOND PROPOSAL IF FORTY
MILLION AND ONE TIME BUDGET FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM THROUGH
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE PLANS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
CAN CREATE THE NUMBER K.
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS
RECEIVING PREVENTATIVE EARLY
INTERVENTION AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES MY SCHOOL
AFFILIATED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS. BUT A LOT OF
PROPOSED. WILL BE DISCUSSED IN
DETAIL DURING THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING FOR HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. I THINK
WITH MY REMARKS AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU L. L. EMAIL ME WITH THE L.
A. L. WE WANTED TO SHARE SOME
BACKGROUND AND THEN ARE
ASSESSMENT AND RECOMMENDATION
ON THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOL
MENTAL. I'M IN RECENT YEARS
NUMEROUS REPORTS HAVE INDICATED
MORE STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THESE
ISSUES APPEAR TO HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED DURING THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC THE STATE SYSTEM FOR
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
HOWEVER IS FRAGMENTED AND
INCLUDES VARIOUS ENTITIES WITH
OVERLAPPING RESPONSIBILITIES A
CHILD WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
COULD RECEIVE EDUCATION RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FROM HER
SCHOOL AND ALSO RECEIVE
SERVICES FROM THEIR HEALTH PLAN
ORANGE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT FOR MEDICAL REASONS
AND THE SERVICE IS OFTEN ARE
PROVIDED WITHOUT COORDINATION
ACROSS ENTITIES. ITS
RECOMMENDATION BECOMES AN ISSUE
WHEN THE STATE WANTS TO
INCREASE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR CHILDREN BUT IT'S NOT
ENTIRELY CLEAR WHAT THE BEST
APPROACH WOULD BE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL PROVIDES
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING POP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING TO MATCH
COUNTY SPENDING ON CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH PROJECTS THE
PROPOSAL AIMS TO INCREASE
COUNTY SPENDING ON CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH. GENERALLY GIVEN
CONCERNS OVER STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH WE THINK PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING TO
INCREASE SCHOOL BASED SERVICES
IS REASONABLE HOWEVER WE HAVE
SEVERAL CONCERTS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FIRST AND
FOR MOST OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL LARGELY OVERLAPS AND
DUPLICATES OTHER SCHOOL MENTAL
HEALTH BUDGET PROPOSALS
CURRENTLY BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE FOR INSTANCE AS
FINANCE MENTIONED IN THIS
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO
AUGMENT A SEPARATE EXISTING
GRANT PROGRAMS FOR COUNTY
SCHOOL PARTNERSHIPS BECAUSE
EXISTING PARTNERSHIP GRANTS AND
THE MATCHING FUNDS SHARE MANY
SIMILARITIES. BOTH ARE
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAMS
TARGETED TO COUNTY SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS TO INCREASE SCHOOL
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THE MOST NOTABLE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT THE MATCHING FUNDS ARE
ADMINISTERED BY CVG SCHOOLS
RATHER THAN EIGHT THROUGH A
STATE COMMISSION TO COUNTIES AS
IS THE CASE WITH THE EXISTING
PARTNERSHIP GRANTS HOW THESE
PROPOSALS ARE INTENDED TO BE
COORDINATED IS UNCLEAR
ESPECIALLY SINCE NOTHING
PREVENTS DISTRICTS FROM
RECEIVING BOTH OF THE
PARTNERSHIP GRANT AND THE
MATCHING FUNDS WHICH WOULD
LIMIT OTHER DISTRICTS ACCESS TO
THESE BONDS. ADDITIONALLY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
FOCUSED ON STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELL BEING COULD
POLLACHI FOR MATCH FUNDS MAYBE
ACTIVITY BUT ALSO BE FUNDED I
OTHER. FOR THANK YOU WE ARE. IF
THE MATCHING FUNDS WOULD
ULTIMATELY INCREASE COUNTY
SPENDING ON CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH AS INTENDED. THE STATE
DOESN'T COLLECT DATA ON COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH SPENDING ON
CHILDREN'S SERVICES MEANING IT
WOULD BE DIFFICULT TO KNOW
WHETHER THE PROPOSED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION. WHAT ABOUT SHE
KNEW COUNTY SPENDING OR MATCH
EXISTING FUNDS THAT ARE ALREADY
DEDICATED TO THESE SERVICES.
LASTLY WE HAVE SEVERAL
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THE LIKELY
IMPACT OF THIS PROPOSAL LARGELY
DUE TO THE LACK OF DETAIL
AVAILABLE. OUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT MANY OF THESE DETAILS
WOULD BE LEFT UP TO SEE DO EAT
AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
DECIDE. AS A RESULT IT'S-
UNCLEAR HOW APPLICATIONS WOULD
BE PRIORITIZED AND WHAT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACT OF THIS
PROGRAM WOULD BE. FOR ITS AND
IT'S UNCLEAR HOW MANY PRODUCTS
ARE LIKELY TO RECEIVE FINDING
WHETHER TO EXPAND ITS FINDINGS.
EXPANDED SERVICES COULD BE
SUSTAINED WITHOUT MATCHING
FUNDS AND HOW THE APPLICATION
IT WOULD ADDRESS THAT BEING A
TEACHER THE EXISTING
PARTNERSHIPS WOULD HAVE AND
APPLYING. IT IN OUR SYSTEM WE
HAVE TWO RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE FIRST WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE FIND
A WORKGROUP FOCUSED ON STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE STRATEGY FOR
COORDINATING SERVICES. GIVEN
THE FACT MEDITATION AND LACK OF
COORDINATION IN THE CURRENT
STATE SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH. ACROSS AGENCY
WORKER COULD IDENTIFY GAPS. IN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN. WARNING SERVICES.
THAT'S PRACTICES FOR INTER.
COLLABORATION SO. REVENUE
SOURCE INCLUDING WHETHER
ONGOING POP NINETY EIGHT FUNDS
ARE NEEDED AND RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR A MORE COORDINATED
STATEWIDE APPROACH TO
INCREASING ACCESS. TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN SCHOOLS IN A
SCHOOL SETTING. SECONDLY WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
REJECTS THE MATCHING FUNDS
PROPOSAL THE MATCHING FUNDS
PROPOSAL LARGELY DUPLICATE.
OTHER EFFORTS OF OTHER PROPOSED
PROGRAMS WILL REQUIRE SOME TIME
TO RESULT IN AN INCREASE WILL
BE SERVICES. AND WOULD HAVE
LIMITED IMPACT OVER TIME AND
ACROSS THE STATE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REVISIT
ONGOING COMPANY FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH AT A
LATER TIME AFTER A RECOMMENDED
WORKER COMPLETES ITS WORK. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR REMARKS BUT
HAVING TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
OKAY QUESTIONS. YEAH I'LL START
HERE SO AS WITH THE LAST ISSUED
SEEMS THAT WE RIGHTFULLY SO
TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE ON A
REGULAR BASIS CERTAINLY. THE
NEW MENTAL AT THE APRIL HEALTH
OF OUR STUDENTS IS AS IT YOU
KNOW AS A BIG FACTOR IN STUDENT
SUCCESS AND SO WE ALL WANT TO.
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS- HI I DO
NOT. OVER THE YEARS WE'VE
INCREASED MONEY FOR PROP SIXTY
THREE THROUGH THE COUNTY IS
GOING DIRECTLY TO THE SCHOOLS
AND SO WE HAVE KIND THIS
HODGEPODGE. OF SUPPORT WHICH
THE L. A. O. NOTES. AND- THANK
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT SOMETHING
THEY'RE ON TO SOMETHING AS FAR
AS- HAVING MORE COORDINATION
AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
THE WORKGROUP TECH TO BETTER
COORDINATE. I JUST MUCH CERTAIN
IF EVERY YEAR WE HAVE- WE HAVE
PART OF MONEY OVER HERE WE CAN
FOCUS ON IT WE GIVE IT RIGHT TO
HELP ELEAZAR AND I'M NOT SURE
IF IT'S- IF WE'RE FOCUSING AND
ACCORDING MANNER SO WHAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HOW DO YOU RESPOND TO
THAT. HOW I'M GONNA FINANCE BUT
WE SEE THAT CURRENT PROPOSALS
OF WORKING TOGETHER TO HELP
BRING DIFFERENT ENTITY TO THE
TABLE TO BALTIMORE COMPETE WITH
THEM DEPARTAMENTAL HOCKEY FOR
CHILDREN THE GOAL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IF INCREASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
FOR AROUND FOUR AND THE THREE
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE
CURRENTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND TO PROVIDE DISCONTENT THAT
EACH ENTITY THE DALLAS A THREE
WAY PARTNERSHIP BECAUSE WE'RE
AWARE THAT THERE HAVEN'T BEEN
CHALLENGES IN. COORDINATING
EFFORTS IN THE PAST. MY EIGHT
MATCH AND THE ALLEY TO WORK
WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. THAT AND MAKE A THE
STATE PARK PLANS BY THE COUNTY
TO WORK WITH THE AID. AND I
THINK ETHICAL AND THE MEDIC
MANAGED PLANS WORK WITH L. AND
COUNTY. ALL PEOPLE IN TO BUILD
BETTER RELATIONS WE CAN VARIOUS
ENTITIES THAT CHILDREN. THE
DOCTOR PACKAGE IN FACT TO
BETTER CORNY EFFORTS. TO
LEVERAGE DATING BACK. IN ORDER
TO MARK. ADDRESS NOT HEALTH
NEEDS THE. SO DOES THIS MEAN AS
FAR AS AND CAL. THERE'S A
SCHOOL THIS RIGHT THE STREET
HERE. ZACKS OR TWIN RIVERS.
SILVA THOSE L. A. GET RID TO
HIGH MORE. PERSONNEL ON CAMPUS
OR THE BEACH. CONTRACTED
THROUGH HEALTH AGENCIES WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT WILL THIS MEAN
TO A COMMUNITY THAT CREDIT AND-
AND EDUCATION COMMUNITY THAT
HAS A DESIRE FOR INCREASED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR
THEIR KIDS. SEARCH FOR THAT
PERFECT PROP NINETY EIGHT MATCH
A WEEK YOU HAVE AT. SEVERAL
ACTIVITIES WITH THAT I THINK
ARE ALSO LISTED ON YOUR EXACT
BY WHAT THE FUNDING COULD BE
USED FOR THAT COULD INCLUDE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
EDUCATORS IDENTIFY EARLY
WARNING SIGNS AND RISK FACTORS
THE NEED OF MEDICAL HELP THE
FIGHT. EXPANDING MEDICAID
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING FACT
DEVELOPING SUPPORT NETWORK
DEVELOPING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND
DEVELOPING A REPORT. TO THE
POINT. THAT. OKAY SO CAN WE GO
BACK TO L. A. L. DO YOU THINK
WE HAVE. ADEQUATE COORDINATION
TEAM TO MAXIMIZE. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR L. A.'S TO HIRE PERSONNEL.
IN NEARLY FROM L. A. L. I THINK
THEY WERE JUST HARKEN BACK TO
THE INITIAL COMMENTS THAT WE
NEED- AND- ASSESSMENT- OUR
FINDINGS WAS THAT THERE WERE
ARE A FAIR NUMBER OF ENTITIES
THAT ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THIS INCLUDES
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
ESPECIALLY AS FAR AS SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES GO THIS
INCLUDES- HEALTH PLANS BOTH
PRIVATE AND- MEDICAL OR
MEDICARE. AND ALL OUR BACK CAL
MOST LIKELY- AND ALSO COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT I THINK THE
CHALLENGING THING IS THERE'S NO
COORDINATION ACROSS THESE
ENTITIES AND SO IT'S HARD TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER OR OT THERE
ARE GAPS SERVICE GAPS WHEN IT
COMES TO CHILDREN MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES SO I THINK THAT IS
KIND OF WHY IT AT MOTIVATED OUR
RECOMMENDATION TO PROVIDE A
WORKER THAT WHICH TAKE A MORE
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO. EXAMINING
THE ISSUE AND THEN ALSO
CHARGING A CROSS AGENCY WORK
GROUP WITH RESPONSIBILITY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE PROVIDE. A
CONTINUUM OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATES. THANK
YOU MISTER ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT THAT- IS NOTED IS HOW MANY
ELEAZAR DOES THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SPEAK FUNDING WITH THE
PROPOSED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
INVESTMENT. AND HOW WILL THE
ELEAZAR STAYING FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. OFTEN THE
CHECKING ACCOUNT OF FINANCE IF
WE WERE TO STRUCTURE THE GRANT
FROM WORK TO THE ANYTHING ABOUT
THE PARTNERSHIP GRANT BECAUSE
EXPECTED FINDING IT QUITE ABOUT
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY PARTNER SET.
HOWEVER IT ALSO BELIEVE THE
DEPEND ON THE GRANT AWARD
AMOUNT AND THAT WOULD BE
DETERMINED AS PART OF A
COMPETITIVE APPLICATION PROCESS.
I NOTED IN THE L. A. O.'S
COMMENTS- THERE THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO APPROVE
THE ONE TIME AUGMENTATION. AND
WHAT THEY NOTE ON THEIR IS TO
REQUIRE GRANTS TO BE AWARDED TO
UNFUNDED PARTNERSHIP
APPLICATION APPLICATIONS WHAT
IS YOUR THOUGHT ON THAT. THE
PROBLEM NINETY EIGHT NOT OUT WE
DID NOT INCLUDE ANY PRIORITIES.
AND OF COURSE WE WOULD LOOK. IT
QUITE FOR THE NHS OF THE
PARTNERSHIP PRACTICE AT OUR
FEET Y. BUT THAT WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE APPLY FOR THE PAST
NINETY MATCH- IN THE L. A. O.
SCOTT. THEY TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT. THE MENTALHEALTH THAT IS
NEEDED FOR STUDENTS. IS NEEDED
NOW. AND IF YOU BEGIN THIS
PROCESS OF PUTTING TOGETHER
YOUR APPLICATION THE AMOUNT OF
TIME IS GOING TO BE SPENT TO
TRY TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE
YOU FINALLY SELECT WHO YOU'RE
GOING TO PARTNER WITH. IS NOT
GOING TO FULFILL THE NEED FOR
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES NOW
IN THE MAKE IT IN THE MEDIA
TIME. WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT. WE STRUCTURE THE MASS OF
THE COMPETITIVE GRANT IN ORDER
TO HAVE A PROCESS BY WHICH WE
COULD A WIDE LIMITED FUNDING
THE PROPOSAL THAT BEST MEET THE
GOAL OF THE MATCH PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY GIVEN THE CAN'T
CURRENT CONDITIONS IT MAY BE
BENEFICIAL THAT A WORKOUT
AVAILABLE JULY FIRST. AND WILL
THERE STILL DON'T DEALING WITH
MANY CHALLENGES INCLUDING WILL
BE OPENING IN THE SUMMER AND
FALL HAVING THAT COMPETITIVE
GRANT APPLICATION DEVELOPED AND
BEING RELEASED MONTHS LATER
WOULD ALLOW. FOR MORE
APPLICANTS TO BE READY WITH A
PLAN. WHAT ABOUT THE NEED OF
THE STUDENTS NOW HOW DO YOU
TAKE CARE OF THAT NOW. AND
AGAIN WE STRUCTURE THAT THAT
MAC ATTACK BUT IT OF
REPLICATION PROCESS BUT WE ARE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. CAN OPERATE THE
FACT THAT THE FOR THE DIRECT
LINE OF POLITICAL ARTICLES AND-
ORTING CHRISTMAS I HOPE. WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EIGHTEEN TO
I'M SORRY MR MMHM WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
PARTNERSHIPS. ALTHOUGH HOW MANY
LEDS IN CALIFORNIA. HOW THE
GOVERNOR AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION I WOULD DECIDE TWO
THOUSAND ALLEYS IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE REQUESTED IS TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE MILLION. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF LESS THAN
10% MY GOODNESS LESS THAN 1%
RIGHT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
PARTNERSHIPS IN YOUR TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DELEGATES. TWO
THOUSAND. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT LESS THAN 1% ELLIE
AS- THAT WILL BENEFIT FROM THIS
IS THAT RIGHT. ALBANY N.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE SO THE REACH
WOULD DEPEND ON A NUMBER OF
FACTORS THAT WERE STILL LOOKING
FOR THE PROPOSAL INCLUDING THE
BASE LEVEL THE GRANT AWARD OR
THE PROCESS ALLOCATE WORK TO
COUNTY THE DIFFERENT FIVE
MINUTES. I BASED ON THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE THOSE DETAILS ARE ON
HOW TO STRUCTURE THE GRANT
WOULD BE UP TO THE DISCRETION
OF THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION WELL WE'RE HAPPY TO
LOOK INTO DIFFERENT OPTIONS TO
MAKE SURE OF BAD BATMAN AT THE-
APPRIVER COMMITTEE. ON.
CLARIFYING AND REFINING THE
PROPOSAL. AND I PUT BUT I CAN'T
FOR WHERE MY- WERE BUT WAS ONE
OF THE PROPOSALS ARE ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS FROM LA- TO GIVE
SMALLER. GRANTS SO THAT YOU CAN
HAVE A GREATER REACH. IS THAT
CORRECT ALEJO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ASKED WOULD YOU MIND REPEATING
THE QUESTION WAS ONE OF YOUR
SUGGESTIONS THAT- THE GROUNDS
V. SMALLER SO THAT YOU CAN HAVE
A GREATER REACH AND- MORE
ELEAZAR. OF MORELIA
PARTNERSHIPS. I'M I THINK ONE
OF OUR CONCERNS AND WAYS THAT
THEIR WIVES NO UPPER LIMIT IN
TERMS OF THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
MATCH AND SO FOR INSTANCE IF A
COUNTY ALREADY SPENDS. TWENTY
MILLION SO YOU HAVE L. A.
COUNTY THAT SPENDS TWENTY
MILLION ON CHILDREN'S MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND THAT-
COUNTY WORKS WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT PUTS IN A VERY A
ROBUST APPLICATION I THINK THE
CONCERN WOULD BE THAT THOSE.
LARGER DISTRICTS COULD EXHAUST
THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION RATHER
QUICKLY- I THINK OUR OVERALL
RECOMMENDATION WISE TO REJECT
THE MATCHING FUNDS PROPOSAL
BECAUSE THERE ARE JUST A FAIR
NUMBER OF CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
IN TERMS OF MEETING IF THAT.
INTENDED OBJECTIVES. THANK YOU.
BYE MY LAST QUESTION A PROBLEM
CHAIR- IT MANY IN THE AND MAYBE
THE QUESTION IS INAPPROPRIATE
BUT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM SO MANY OF
OUR SCHOOLS THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH COUNSELORS AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS ON
CAMPUS. CAN'T WE USE FUNDS LIKE
THIS TO INCREASE THE CANCERS
THE COUNSELOR TO STUDENT RATIO
ON CAMPUSES- IT ESTABLISH
STUDENT HEALTH CENTERS WELLNESS
CENTERS WOULDN'T THAT BE BETTER.
A BETTER WAY TO SPEND THE MONEY.
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION IN
OUR CURRENT PROPOSAL THE
ESTABLISHMENT OR EXPANSION OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND COUNSELING
STAFF AVAILABLE FOR IS AS AN
OPTION TO USE THE FIND OUT THAT
WORK FAMILY HAPPY YOUR OTHER
COMPETENCY CONSIDERATION. AS WE
CONTINUE WORKING ON A FOOTBALL.
THANK YOU. OKAY A SINGLE
FURTHER QUESTIONS WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OPEN AS WELL ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR FOUR SCHOOL CLIMATE
DATA. HI GOOD EVENING CHEN
MEMBERS MICHELLE YEAH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- SO I
PLAYED OUT IN THE AGENDA THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES TEN
MILLION ONE TIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT TO PROVIDE
ENHANCED SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEY
RESOURCES. SO UNDER TEN MILLION
A MINIMUM OF FIVE MILLION WILL
BE A CONTRACT WITH A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY MOST LIKELY A
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION- TO
BAT AND MAKE AVAILABLE SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS AND TO PROVIDE
TRAINING TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ON. THE TAPE AND ANALYSIS- IN
THIS PIECE WE ESPECIALLY WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT BECAUSE WE
ENVISION THE BULK OF THE WORK
THAT THE COUNTY OFFICE WILL BE
DOING IS PROVIDING SUPPORT AND
RESOURCES FOR DISTRICTS TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE
AND INTERPRET THE DATA THEY ARE
GATHERING FROM THE START IT'S-
SO THERE ARE MANY FUNDING FOR A
MAXIMUM OF FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. WILL BE ALLOCATED AS-
MANY GRANTS OR GRANTS TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF DECIDED
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS- WE WANT
DISTRICTS TO CONTINUE TO USE
THESE TOOLS TO HELP INFORM
THEIR CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
PROCESS EACH- AND WE ALSO HOPE
THAT THE FUNDING WILL ENCOURAGE
DISTRICTS TO ADMINISTER A
CLIMATE SURVEY EVERY YEAR AS
OPPOSED TO EVERY OTHER YEAR AS
IS CURRENTLY REQUIRED- I
SPECIALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT TO
CREATE A NEW CLIMATE SURVEY OUR
TOOL- BUT RATHER TO ENSURE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE. ACCESS
AND ARE USING RELIABLE CLIMATE
SURVEYS THAT CAN GIVE THEM
INSIGHT INTO THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES I'M
ESPECIALLY NOW DURING THESE
HARD TIMES- AND PERHAPS MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE GOAL OF THIS%
PROPOSAL IS REALLY TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN DOING- THE VERY
COMPLICATED WORK. OFTHE
DISAGGREGATED AND INTERPRETING
THE DATA THAT THEY GATHER FROM
SURVEYS- TO INFORM THEIR NEXT
STEPS IN A CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS. AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. OKAY NEXT PRESENT.
THE NATURE MEMBERS MICHAEL
AGAIN WITH THE ILLEGAL WELL WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS ISSUE
WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT IN
REVIEWING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WE HAVE SOME SIMILAR
QUESTIONS THOSE OF A REASON
YOU'RE IN GENERAL IN TERMS OF
THE VALUE IN THE PROPOSAL WHO
WOULD YOU THINK IT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER AND
CLARIFY HOW THIS PROPOSAL
COMPLIMENTS IT DOESN'T
DUPLICATE ANY OF THE STATE'S
EXISTING OR RELATED TO HEALTHY
KIDS SURVEY AND OTHER SUPPORT
AND ASSISTANCE THAT THE STATE
PROVIDES TO SCHOOL DISTRICT
SIZE ISSUES. THOSE ARE OUR
COMMENTS. AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I LIKE ON ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IN
ASSESSING COMMUNITY NEEDS IN
THE WAKE OF THE COCA NINETEEN
CANTIK AND DISTANCE LEARNING AT
THE FBI HAS STATE OF THE
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES FOR
OUR STUDENTS FROM FAMILIES AND
ALL OF OUR EDUCATORS BEING AWAY
FROM THE CLASSIC BUT BUT THE
THING AWAY FROM CLASSROOMS
FRIENDS TEACHERS AN EXTRA-CORRECTLY EXTRACURRICULAR
ACTIVITIES WHILE ADJUSTING TO
DISTANCE LEARNING. HAS BEEN A
LOT FOR STUDENTS TO DEAL WITH
WE MUST DO ALL WE CAN TO
ADDRESS SOCIAL AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND MENTAL HEALTH OF
OUR STUDENTS THAT IS WHY NOW
MORE THAN EVER WE NEED SERVICES
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS MENTAL
HEALTH WE WOULD NOTE THAT CAL
SCHOOLS WHICH IS ACTUALLY CAL
S. C. H. L. S. AS AN ACRONYM
WAS REVISING THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR TO
SUPPORT SURVEYS ACROSS
DIFFERENT SCHOOL SETTING
DISTANCE LEARNING IN PERSON AND
HYBRID. THE SURVEY QUESTIONS
WERE EXPANDED TO ASSESS MORE
AREAS RELATED TO SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL HEALTH SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND STUDENTS
EXPERIENCES LEARNING FROM HOME
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT C. E.
HAS EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE WITH
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS AND MAY
SERVE AS A BETTER AND TO TEACH
A FACILITY THAT'S PROPOSAL FOR
EXAMPLE ONE OPTION IS TO START
WITH THE EXISTING SUITE OF
SURVEILLANCE CAL SCHOOL.
ADMINISTRATOR ADMINISTERED BY
FEET THROUGH A CONTRACT WITH
WEST DAD WESTEND HAVE INDICATED
THAT THE SERVICE CAN BE UPDATED
TO ASSESS AND MERGING NEEDS
RESULTING FOR THEM FROM THE
PANDEMIC WE ESTIMATE THAT A
TOTAL COSTS TO ADMINISTER CAL
TELL SCHOOLS ANNUALLY IN ALL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
AND PROVIDE RELATED TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS WOULD BE ABOUT THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. IF THE PROPOSED TEN
MILLION IS USED TO CONTACT WITH
THAT AT WEST DAD INSTEAD OF
FINDING A COUNTY OFFICE
CALIFORNIA COULD COULD SUPPORT
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEY
ADMINISTRATION FOR ALL ELEAZAR
AT NO COST TO ELEAZAR AND
PROVIDE TECH AT PROVIDE
TRAINING TALLIES IN DATA USE
FOR CONTINUOUS SCHOOL
IMPROVEMENT FOR THREE YEARS.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
DESIGNATED FUNDING FOR TO
SUPPORT HEALTH SCHOOLS THE CITY
HAS BEEN RELYING ON
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS FROM
DIFFERENT PROGRAM OFFICES TO
FUND THE SURVEY IS A STABLE
FUNDING SOURCE TO APPROPRIATE.
SUPPORT TELL SCHOOLS THE TOOL
BUT PRODUCE VALUE AT THE- ME
THE- THAT ACTUALLY. THE AND
REAL SCHOOL DATA THEY'RE ALL
USED BY THE- OF. ALLEY A- WOULD
MEET THE STATED OBJECTIVES OF
THIS PROPOSAL I HAVE WITH ME
BARBARA MURCHISON DIRECTOR OF
THE EDUCATOR EXCELLENCE AND
EQUITY DIVISION TO ANSWER ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I DO NOT- HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOUR SPEAKER
BUT MAYBE LOOK FOR L. A. L- I
THOUGHT THAT WAS IT. YEP
QUESTIONER YES IT IS THE BIG
PICTURE IS OF COURSE THE DAYS
WERE THE OFFSHOOTS OF THE L. C.
F. F. IN THE L. CAP PROCESS
AND- I KNOW. WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS THROUGHOUT THE YEARS YOU
HAD MIXED RESULTS IN. IN AN
ENGAGEMENT AND HOW THIS REALLY
WORKS ON A PRACTICAL LEVEL SO.
JUST JUST WONDERED. IF ANYBODY
COULD LIGHTNESS OF HOW. WE'VE
EVOLVED AND CHANGE THAT FOR
EXAMPLE USES EXAM THIS THIS
POINT TWO YEARS AGO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN DAVIS. THEY SENT
OUT AN EL CAP FLYER THEY HAD
LIKE A BASEBALL CAP ON THERE.
THEY'RE RYING TO BE CUTE AND
SO PEOPLE THOUGHT THERE WAS
LIKE LITTLE LEAGUE SIGN UPS AND
IT WAS LIKE IT'S SO. TRYING TO
ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY DOESN'T
ALWAYS WORK AND SO. WHAT HAVE
WE LEARNT AND HOW ARE WE
EVOLVING TO MAKE SURE THE
NOTION THIS IS GOOD WE WANT TO
PUT MORE MONEY OUT TO LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. HAVE THEM
MAKE THEIR DECISIONS- GRAMMAR
NOT ALWAYS HAPPY WITH THEM LAST
YEAR WE'VE DONE IS THAT- WAS
GLORIA OPENINGS BUT- THAT'S
THAT'S A PIECE BUT ALSO THESE-
EL CAP PROCESS WITH THAT THE
SCHOOL CLIMATE DATA AND SO
FORTH SO. HOW ARE WE EVOLVING.
DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY. AND
ALICE'S ABOUT THAT-
SUGGESTIONS. BASED BESIDES WHAT
WE HAVE IN THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
RIGHT HERE. I THINK I KNOW THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT I WOULD
NOTE THAT LAST YEAR THE CAL
SCHOOLS SURVEYED WAS REVISED
FOR TO SUPPORT SURVEYS ACROSS
DIFFERENT SCHOOL SETTING- WELL
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S HOW
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE
EVOLUTION I CAN POINT TO THE
FACT THAT. WE DO ADOPT THESE
SURVEYS AS NEEDED CAN I ASK L.
A. L. D. DO YOU THINK THAT THE
SURVEYS AND THE PROCESS IS
WORKING ESPECIALLY AS IT WAS
INTENDED TO WHEN WE- PROVE THAT
THIS L. C. F. F. IN A REFORM IN
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN I GUESS.
YOUR FAVORITE WELCOME IS THERE
ON PURPOSE I THINK PART OF THE
QUESTION HERE ILLEGALLY.
IMPROVE ON THE GOAL OF THE
CIRCADIAN WHERE YOU'RE HOPING
TO DO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY OF ONE KIND
OF MORE CONSISTENT SET OF
QUESTIONS THAT YOU COULD HAVE-
SCHOOLMISTRESS DISTRICTS ASK
FOR- I THINK IT. WAS GOING ON
IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND THEIR-
IN THE SCHOOL. ON THIS A LOT OF
THE TO LOOKING WHAT'S GOING ON
ACROSS THE STATE YOU FULLER
WITH- BUT THE DOCTORS WE'VE
TAKEN THE BOTH THE PAST. AND IN
THE- THE- WE USE FOR OUR
DISTRICTS YOU CAN. WHAT'S GOING
ON AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THIS
CORRECT THAT THE BILL WOULD BE
PERCENT DISTRICTS CHOOSE
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO DO SO
YOU'RE NOT A PRIVILEGE TO WORK
WITH THE BIG SCHOOL DISTRICTS
YOU CAN DECIDE WHAT YOU WANT TO
DO. MAYBE YOU WANT TO TRY
DIFFERENT SURVEYS OF DIFFERENT
APPROACHES TO GET. GOING ON.
THAT KIND OF INFORMATION IS NOT
AVAILABLE FORWARD LOOKING AT
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE STATE
LEVEL. FOR TRACKING CHANGES
OVER TIME. THE QUESTION IS WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR PRIMARY WOULD
BE TO IF YOU WANT TO BE AWAY TO
GET HELP AND SOME OF THE HOLES
OF WHAT'S GOING ON. THE WOULD
YOU TAKE A NEW APPROACH TO THE
MOST TO. THE CARD. BECAUSE
THREE OR DO YOU WANT TO
SOMETHING. THAT IS VERY LOCAL
AND SPECIFIC TO A COMMUNITY. IN
WHICH CASE IT WANT TO BE
LOOKING AT MORE DEVELOPING THE-
MORNING YOU COULD SPECIFIC.
ANSWERING MY BENEFIT CONCERT
THAT MANY MORE. IN LINE WITH
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS.
SURE MAYBE THIS IS A QUESTION
MORE FOR. OVERSIGHT AND- MAYBE
THE STATE AUDITOR OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE I JUST HAVE
ONGOING ISSUES AS FAR AS- THE
INTENT AND WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING IN THE REAL WORLD SO-
I DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON THE JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR. SAY NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WILL HOLD THIS IS.
DULCIMER BAIDU'S. I AM WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL CREATE A
NEW REQUIREMENT FOR ANNUAL
SCHOOL CLIMATE SURVEYS AND
REQUIRE ALLEYS TO USE SPECIFIC
SURVEY INTERESTED IN FROM
INSTRUMENTS THAT ARE VETTED AND
APPROVED. SO TO GET A PERMANENT
FINANCE AGAIN- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL DOES NOT CREATE ANY
REQUIREMENTS IT WOULD JUST MAKE
THESE RESOURCES AVAILABLE- TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THE
REQUIREMENT THAT. SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEYS BE CONDUCTED
EVERY OTHER YEAR WHAT STILL
STANDS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL SO THAT WOULD STAFF
FOR SO THAT WOULD LOCAL SURVEY
INSTRUMENTS THAT ARE NOT VETTED
APPROVED CONTINUE TO BE ALLOWED
FOR THE LOCAL. AFTER THE L.
CATS A GOAL. SETTING AND
MONITORING FOR. A AT ALL THE
YES YES. YOU KNOW IT'S GOING TO
IS YOU A KIND SURVEYS THEY- IT
HELPFUL AND THE LOCAL NEEDS
THEY COULD STILL. GREAT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU THIS ISSUE
BE HELD OPEN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
THIS IS NOT A BUDGET ITEM BUT
A- AND INFORMATIONAL ITEM.
RELATED TO SCHOOL SYSTEMS
INTERVENTIONS AND SUPPORTS.
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE L.
A. L. AND CD. I AM SEVENTY
AGAIN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
SO IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I
WILL KEEP MY COMMENTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE GREAT
GRIEF AND SIMILARLY TO WHAT IS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- AND I
WILL ALSO DELVE INTO FUNDING
PROVIDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION TO PROVIDE
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE. I
WAS ORDERED TO ALIGN WITH THE
EXPECTED WORKLOAD OF THE
COLLABORATIVE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A TOTAL OF
TWELVE POINT FOUR SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT WHICH IS AN INCREASE OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND
OVER THE AMOUNT THAT WAS.
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
SECOND. I WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WHAT IS GOVERNOR'S. IS A-
COUNTY OFFICE ABOUT. AND
DIFFERENTIATED ASSIST. ELIGIBLE
GUEST ELIGIBLE DISTRICTS- THE
GOVERNOR'S BY. AND SEVENTY TWO
POINT FOUR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT IN BOTH CURRENT YEAR. AND
BUDGET YEAR- FOR COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO AT
LEAST TO IMPROVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES. THIS IS AN INCREASE
OF FOUR POINT SEVEN THREE
MILLION AND CURRENT AND BUDGET
YEAR- COMPARED TO WHAT WAS
BUILT INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT. AND IT REFLECTS THE
FACT THAT THE DASHBOARD WAS
SUSPENDED IN TWENTY TWENTY SO
THE NUMBER OF ELEAZAR
IDENTIFIED FOUR DIFFERENT TO
GET SYSTEMS WAS HELD CONSTANT-
IN TWENTY TWENTY. SB NINETY.
AND OTHER TWENTY NINETEEN
DASHBOARD IDENTIFIED TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE ONLY EIGHT
SO THAT'S- SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICES. THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- AND
THAT'S DOWN FROM TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FOR THE ELIGIBLE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AS YOU NOW
FUNDING FOR COUNTY OFFICES IS
PROVIDED THROUGH A STATUTORILY
DRIVEN FORMULA. AND THAT TAKES
INTO CONSIDERATION BOTH THE
SIZE OF THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN MY COUNTY THAT ARE ELIGIBLE.
FOR DIFFERENT SYSTEMS- AND IT'S
BASED ON A THREE YEAR OLD
AVERAGE. AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK
THANK YOU L. A. L. IN ME WITH
THE L. A. L. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
AT COMMON AT THIS TIME BUT
HAPPY ANY. THANK YOU. OKAY CITY.
YES I LIKE HONOR ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION THE CITY IS
CONTINUING TO PROVIDE
DIFFERENTIATED AS ASSISTANT
SUPPORT TO THE THEORIES THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED THE LAST TIME
THE CALIFORNIA THAT CALIFORNIA
PUBLISHED A SCHOOL DASHBOARD
WHICH WAS TWENTY NINETEEN AND
WE PLAN TO CONTINUE THE SUPPORT
FOR THOSE SCHOOLS THROUGH AT
LEAST DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ONE OR UNTIL SEE WE'VE HAD THAT
TOOK DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
WHEN ANY DASHBOARD IS PUBLISHED.
PROVIDING DIFFERENTIATED. TO
DISTRICT. WHO IDENTIFIED WITH
THE TWENTY NINETEEN DASHBOARD
ARE ALSO PLANNING TO CONTINUE
EIGHT CONTINUE WITH THEIR
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT FOR AT LEAST DECEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. EXAMPLES OF
THE LOCAL DATA THAT. WE ARE
USING IN THEIR CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT WORK INCLUDE BUT
ARE NOT LIMITED TO. SURVEY DATA
COLLECTED VIA EMAIL OR PHONE
FROM STUDENTS TEACHERS FAMILY
PARENTS AND SCHOOL SUPPORT
STAFF. ATTENDANCE AND
INTERACTION DATA DURING
SYNCHRONOUS AND ASYNCHRONOUS
LEARNING. ACCESS TO SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING SUPPORT
INCLUDING THE CASELOAD EXTENT
TO WHICH LESSONS INCORPORATE AT
THE L. CASE LOADS OF STAFF
PROVIDING AT THE L. ASSIGNMENT
FREQUENCY COMPLETION DATA AT
THE STATE LEVEL NON PARTICIPANT
AND PARTICIPANTS CLASSROOM
OBSERVATION DATA. AND WITH THE
ENERGY DATA BOTH FORMAL AND
INFORMAL AND FINALLY STUDENT
TEACHER WILL STAY AND STAFF
WELL BEING. I HAVE WITH ME
REGIONAL NAMES DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT HERE AT CITY.
AND LENDS ITSELF TOWARD A TORY
DIRECTOR OF THE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND SUPPORT
DIVISION. TO ANSWER ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU. I JUST WANT TO
PROBE THE ONE ISSUE THAT WAS
WRITTEN UP IN THE AGENDA.
CERTAINLY WE VALUE AND
APPRECIATE THIS WORK IT'S
ALWAYS IMPORTANT WHAT'S THE
RELATION TO WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH OUR SCHOOLS WERE THREE
OPENING. AND AND HOW THIS
IMPACTS IF CAPACITY CHALLENGES
WORKLOAD. THOSE ISSUES. AMBER
ALEXANDER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I'LL I'LL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE THAT QUESTION- SO
CERTAINLY WE ARE- AND CAREFULLY
MONITORING THAT THOSE
DISCUSSIONS- AT AS I KNOW-
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE ARE
AS WELL- IN TERMS OF CAPACITY
ISSUES- YOU KNOW WHEN WE PUT
TOGETHER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE DID- HAVE CONVERSATIONS- YOU
KNOW WITH WITH THAT
COLLABORATIVE- WHOWE KNOW YOU
KNOW PLAYS A KEY ROLE IN THE
ONGOING- EFFORTS AROUND RE
OPENING SCHOOLS. AS WELL AS
VARIOUS COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION- OBVIOUSLY THERE
WASN'T TIME YOU KNOW THERE
WASN'T A PATH FORWARD ON RE
OPENING AT THE TIME THAT THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL WAS PUT FORWARD
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT WILL NEED
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS AS WE
MOVE TOWARDS SPRING- AND
POTENTIALLY REASSESS THAT
WORKLOAD IN LIGHT OF. THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY OCCURRING. OKAY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. I DO NOT
HAVE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- YES IT WAS IT- ACTION
ITEM AS WELL- WITH THAT THAT
CONCLUDES THE FIVE ISSUES ON
TODAY'S ABBREVIATED AGENDA OF
COURSE THIS WAS JUST A FOLLOW
UP TO FINISH YES A NUMBER OF
ITEMS I DON'T I DON'T FEAR THE
START. I WON'T BE TOO LONG I
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE NOT ONLY GOOD
AFTER A LONG RUNNING HERE. AND
WILL THEN SEE ABOUT
MODIFICATIONS APPROVED BY THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
RESULT IN VALID AND RELIABLE
DATA THAT CAN BE PUBLISHED IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DASHBOARD. AND USED TO IDENTIFY
ELOISE IN NEED OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT. SO I
WILL DEFER TO YOU RACHEL NAMES
THE DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION AS A
CONTRACTED EXCUSE ME. IN THE
INSTRUCTION AND MEASUREMENT
BRANCH JUST ON THAT WITH THE
STATE BOARD UPON THEIR
MOVEMENTS ON ASSESSMENTS AND IT
HADN'T ASKRI TOLD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. EVERYONE YOU HAVE TO
FORGIVE ME FOR SOME REASON MY
CAMERA IS NOW SHOWING ON THE
WRONG SIDE I'VE NEVER FOUND.
THEY MAY JUST HAVE TO. TURN IT
OFF FOR A SECOND. A LOVELY SET
UP. OKAY I JUST HAVE TO SAY I
HAVE BEEN ON ALL DAY AND THIS
COULD NOT HAPPEN BEFORE.
COLLEGE AND- I'M AS FAR. AS FAR
AS YOUR QUESTION GOES ARE YOU
REFERRING TO- THE CAST I DIDN'T
I DIDN'T QUITE CATCH WHAT
ASSESSMENTS YOU ARE REFERENCING
YEAH THE ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE
DUE ANNUALLY- AND REQUIRED TO
BE PUBLISHED ON THE DASHBOARD.
SURE SO WE- HAVE R. E. L. A.
AND MATH ASSESSMENTS- AS FAR AS
YOUR QUESTION GOES REGARDING
WHETHER OR NOT- WE WILL HAVE
VALID AND RELIABLE DATA. TO
PUBLISH ON THE DASHBOARD IS A
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE STILL
HAVING DISCUSSIONS AROUND JUST
TODAY- ARE YOU TWO DAYS AGO WE
RECEIVED GUIDANCE FROM EDIE
YOU. ARE MAKING IT VERY CLEAR
THAT THEY WOULD NOT APPROVE
ANOTHER BLANKET WAIVER OF
ASSESSMENTS BUT ALSO WELL I'M
PROVIDING A LITTLE BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY AND THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO WORK WITH STATES. AS
THEY HAVE A NEED FOR THE STATE
BOARD ACTUALLY HAD A SPECIAL
BOARD MEETING TODAY- STARTING
FROM EIGHT THIRTY AND WE WENT
AND TELL ALMOST TO DELIBERATING
THIS AND HAVING DISCUSSIONS
AROUND WHAT NEXT STEPS MIGHT
BE. THE ASKED AND A DIRECTION
FOR AND THAT IS STATE BOARD
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND- THE
SUPPORT BY CDP TO PRINT BRING
BACK SOME POTENTIAL PROPOSALS
OF WHAT THAT MIGHT MEAN FOR
THIS NEXT YEAR. SO THERE'S A
LOT STILL IN PLAY AN UNKNOWN
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE. ACADEMIC
INDICATORS FOR THIS NEXT YEAR.
GREAT AND I WOULD AND YOU MAY
NOT HAVE THE ANSWERS TO THIS
NOW BUT I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE
THAT. WE START THINKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW HOW THIS DATA IS GOING
TO BE INCORPORATED INTO OUR
MULTI FOR MULTI YEAR DATA.
COLLECTION OF CALCULATIONS AND
WHAT IMPACT IT'S GONNA HAVE IF
WE IF WITH THE LACK OF
ASSESSMENT DATA FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY- END TO
END ACTUALLY YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT- WHAT IMPACT IT'S GONNA
HAVE ON THE STATE'S
LONGITUDINAL DATA AND SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT EFFORTS- AND THEN. MY
NEXT QUESTION IS HOW MANY CELL
BELIEVES HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
TO WORK WITH SEO IS TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. YES THAT'S NOT
INFORMATION THAT I WOULD HAVE-
REGARDING CELL BELIEVES. AT
THAT THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT HAVE THAT
INFORMATION ON IT CORRECT OF
SEXUALLY A DIFFERENT BRANCH BUT
NOT FOR MY BRANCH. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER UNFORTUNATELY
WE DID NOT BRING BACK AT
DIRECTOR OR STAFF T. THIS
MEETING SAY SO UNFORTUNATELY.
WE CAN'T PROVIDE AN ANSWER BUT
WE CAN CERTAINLY GET BACK YEAH
I WOULD DEFINITELY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU KNOW. THE TALK OF
LEARNING ALOT- THE REALITY OF
LEARNING LOSS IN REGRESSION FOR
OUR SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS AS A
REALITY THAT THAT WE WERE WE
ARE FACING AND IS HAVING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON. KNOW
WHAT SUPPORT IS NEEDED AND WHAT
HAS BEEN GIVEN WOULD BE REALLY
BENEFICIAL THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. SEVEN NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS NOW WE WILL- AT
COMMENCE WITH PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR. ALL ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY. WE HAVE NOBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE. NOT SURE DO WE HAVE
PEOPLE QUEUED UP MODERATOR LET
ME GIVE THE NUMBER ONCE MORE-
877-692-8957. 877-692-8957 THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. ACCESS
CODE ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR.
THREE SEVEN. HEY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO. THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE SEVEN ZERO. AND OUR FIRST
PUBLIC COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OBLIGATED REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION I'LL BE VERY BRIEF
BUT I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
FOR THE ADVANCEMENTS MADE IN
COMMUNITIES COLD. THAT INCLUDES
PHONE CALLS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL TO FUND THE
EXPANSION OF THE SUCCESSFUL AND
IN DEMAND PROGRAMS MICHAEL WAS
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH FIFTEEN
SCHOOLS PROVIDING KEY SUPPORT.
TO STUDENTS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES AS OUTLINED BY TDP
BOB I'D ALSO LIKE TO. MENTION
OUR SUPPORT FROM SCHOOL BASED
MEDICAL BUILDING ISSUE WHERE IN
THE RECOMMENDATION- FROM. THE
TASK OF IT SB SEVENTY FIVE TASK
FORCE HAS. BEEN CONSIDERED WE
KNOW THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE
THAT- WE KNOW THIS ISN'T ON
GOING ISSUE AND SO WE-
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS FROM WITH
ACTIVISTS WHO FORWARD- AS FOR
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WE
AGREE THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
PROPOSALS OUT TERE RIGHT NOW
SO WE'RE- ANALYZING AND LOOKING
AT ALL OF THEM. BUT WE DO KNOW
THAT FOR MANY. OF OUR STUDENTS.
A QUESTION THAT ENTIRE- BASED
ON- THE CAN DOWN. ON OUR BLACK
AND BROWN STUDENTS AND WELL AS
YOU KNOW IN THREE. I CHILDREN
OF FAMILIES THE FINANCIAL
WORKERS WHO LACK ACCESS TO
MENTAL SERVICE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON EXTREME
AND ISSUE THE COMING DAYS AND
WEEKS THANK YOU FOR CARING
LEVINE. THANK YOU NEXT.
ENTERNEXT PUBLIC COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JONATHAN FRAT I WILL BE
SPEAKING ON IF YOU THIRTY. AND
ISSUE FIVE SCHOOL CLIMATE DATA
I AM THE FIRST PRESIDENT OF.
COOL EXPLORE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUT COME TODAY I AM NOT
TOO DISTANT AND I EIGHTEEN
INDIVIDUAL EDUCATION PROGRAM
I'M GOING TO CONNECT I AM
PREPARED. TO PROTECT ME. I
THOUGHT HE- THANK YOU J.
RELATED MENTAL SERVICES IN I.
GOVERNMENT UP TO RECEIVE CAL OF
YEARS FOR MY SCHOOL. I THANK
NOT THE CASE ALL. ARE FOCUSED
MENTAL HEALTH HAS BEEN DETECTED
BUT AGAIN I AM BIASED GRATEFUL
THAT THEY- NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET. I'M CONCERNED
THAT IS NOT ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS IT IS NOT A QUICK
GRAB A COLLABORATION WITH
OUTSIDE ORGANIZATIONS AND
AGENCIES. THAT SUPPORT STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH. WELL PART TO
HELP SUPPORT YOUR STAMP OF THE
BAGHDAD AND ELECTRIC RECOMMENDS
THAT THE ISSUE. OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS THE ADDRESS
AND FUTURE DECISIONS. THIS BOOK
DATA I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT
YOU CAN EXPECT SOME. SURVEYS DO
NOT DIG INTO THE IS AFFECT ON.
HI BEEN ANSWERING SERVICE. AND
MILEAGE. REPUBLICAN QUESTIONS
DO NOT APPLY DIRECT BOOKS BIRDS
ARE DIFFICULT TO ANSWER. SORRY
COULD YOU PLEASE CAN CAUSE LEN
TO BROUGHT ENACT. DISCLOSURES
THIS AND MAY NOT A PICTURE OF
HOW STUDENTS FEEL ABOUT THEIR-
AND LET'S GO COMMUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS. I WATCHED SEVERAL
NEED TO HAVE YOUR IT UP HERE
YOU GONE WAY OVER YOUR TIME
LIMIT. THE. EVERYTHING YOU'RE
RIGHT THE COUNTRY THANK YOU
FOR. EXCEPT FOR ME. I ALSO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ACT
SPEAKERS KEEP COMMENTS SIXTY
SECONDS OR LESS SIXTIES OR
MODERATOR NEXT BIG. ENTERNEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU EXPERIMENTAR MY NAME IS
LOOKS ON FRANCE AND I AM WITH
OKAY NOW. WHAT IS THE NUMBER
THREE WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AND POLITICALLY
ABOUT THE FOR MENTAL HEALTH IN
FACT EDWARD MAY BE SEND YOU
FIND MANY OF THE LOCAL HAVE
MERIT. I TOLD ME A LITTLE
CONCERNED. ABOUT HOW THEY WORK
TOGETHER. JEFF FOR IN FOR.
INSTEAD SUBCOMMITTEE THREE ARE
CENTER THREE THE FIVE NINE
DOLLARS MEANT MORE THAN I
HEALTH BECAUSE EVERYTHING ACT
IT INCLUDES THE AMOUNT THAT.
POINT FIVE. WE WILL NEED THAT
AMOUNT IN AND THE REMAINING ONE
SCHOOL COUNTY. THAT ARE READY
TO GO AND WOULD BE IN A TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISES. ABOUT
WHAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU. AND OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TONY TRIGGER- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ON ISSUE
TWO CTA ALIGNS ITSELF WITH BOTH
THE L. A. O. ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
DONALD'S COMMENTS AND ON ISSUE
THREE CTA IS AWAITING SPECIFIC
DETAILS REGARDING THE FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLAR FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR. MANAGED CARE
PROPOSAL BEFORE COMMENTING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU. NEXT OUR COMMENTS
COME WITH DOUBLE COMES FROM THE
LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS KERRY
CAM ON THE HALF THE CHILDREN'S
INSTITUTE A COMPREHENSIVE
CHILDREN'S AGENCY IN LOS
ANGELES WORKING TO TRANSFORM
THE LIVES OF CHILDREN EXPOSED
TO TRAUMA ADVERSITY WE WANT TO
THANK THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
AGAIN MAKING COMMITTEE SCHOOLS
A PRIORITY. NONPROFITS LIKE
CHILDREN'S INSTITUTE ARE KEY TO
THE SUCCESS THE CAN YOU SCHOOLS
WHICH IS ROOTED IN PARTNERSHIPS
THAT LEVERAGE THE ESTABLISHING
TRUSTED NETWORK OF COMMUNITY
BASED RESOURCES HOWEVER
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO INCENTIVE
FOR ELEAZAR ACCESS ESTABLISHING
PROVEN EXPERTISE OF NONPROFITS
TO PARTNERING INTEGRATE THE
SOCIAL AND ACADEMIC SUPPORT
WHICH IS AT THE CORE TECHNICAL
STRATEGY. OUR. HEALTH SERVICES
WE ARE ENGAGING COLLABORATIVE
LEADERSHIP DURING DISTANCE
LEARNING THEIR DRESSING FAMILY
COMMUNITY NEEDS TO ECONOMIC
SUPPORT INCLUDING EXPANDING
LEARNING PPORTUNITIES WHERE
POSSIBLE THIS IS A COMMUTER
SCHOOL WITH AN INTENTIONAL
NONPROFIT PARTNERSHIP WE URGE
THE STATE TO CREATE INCENTIVES
FOR ELLIE EIGHT THE PARTNER
WITH NONPROFITS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING DATE WITH
YOU AND YOUR STAFF ON THIS
IMPORTANT MISSION. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU.
AND OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
THE LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOANNA FRENCH NINETEEN
YOUR MANAGER RESEARCH AND
POLICY AT AND AT THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL AND COUNTY TENNESSEE
THREE I REQUEST A THOUSAND
PARENTS STATEWIDE FOR LOW
INCOME PARENTS THE COLOR TURN
ENGLISH LEARNERS AND PARENTS OF
STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PEOPLE
SEVEN. LINE COMES THE OUR EIGHT
FOUR MONTHS. BY CORPORATE BOTH
ACADEMICALLY AND SPECIALIST
OKAY. WE ASK YOU TO ALLOCATE
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT FOR EACH OF THESE
CHILDREN SUPPORT PROGRAM
STATEWIDE THAT SUPPORT THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH AND ACADEMIC. IN
ADDITION TO WHAT IS ALREADY
BEING PROVIDED TO DISTRICT. WE
URGE YOU TO ADVOCATE FOR
INCREASED FUNDING FOR NONPROFIT
AND PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THAT ARE WORKING TO ADDRESS
BOTH THE ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL FACT THE PREVENT.
YOUR PROGRAMS LIKE ONE TO ONE
AND. SMALL GROUP CARING
LEARNING PODS. AT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT BIG.
ENTERNEXT COMMENT COMES FROM A
LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING NECESSARILY
LET'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
TEACHING CALIFORNIA. WE WANT TO
DISCUSS IT WE FIRST APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S FOCUS ON MENTAL
HEALTH OF THEIR OVERALL WELL
BEING- WE BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD- FOCUS ON INVESTMENTS
THAT WE CAN MAKE NOW THAT
REALLY BUILD THE CAPACITY OF
EDUCATORS AND SCHOOL PLACE TO
FOCUS ON THE WHOLE CHILD. AND
WE DO FISCAL FOR US WILL
CLIMATE DATA AS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOOL WE APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS ON THAT BUT ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF ELLIE GOVERNOR THAT
WE THINK THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE STATEWIDE
DATA CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
STATE THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
IDENTIFY SCHOOLS IN DELEGATES
THAT ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET
THE- NEEDS OF ALL OUR STUDENTS
PARTICULAR MOST MARGINALIZED
STUDENTS AND PUMP TO CREATING.
A POSITIVE SCHOOL CLIMATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD EVENING THIS IS GETTING
OUT ALIVE THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES ORGANIZATION OF ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING CHILDREN
HERE HARPER SAID. WE BELIEVE
THE COMMUNITY. COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE UNIQUELY
DESIGNED DEVELOPED PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH DEPARTMENT
THEY'RE CURRENTLY DOING THAT
NOW TO PROVIDE MEDICAL ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ON SCHOOL WHETHER IT'S
YOUR COMMUNITY FOR PROGRAM OR
STORAGE WILL BECOME A WHOLE
PARTNERSHIP. WE BELIEVE THAT
EVERY DOLLAR NEEDS TO BE
MAXIMIZED ORDER TO MEET THE
IMPROPER INCREDIBLE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS THAT EXIST IN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM NOW PLUS. THE ON
TOP OF PROGRAM ABOUT HIS DENTAL
STUDENTS. WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO ENGAGE THE MANAGED
CARE ORGANIZATIONS CONTINUE TO
DO THAT WORK AS WELL. WE
SUPPORT EACH OF THE PROPOSALS
ON THE AGENDA TODAY INCLUDING
THE INCREASE OF THE AND I
SUSPECT THEY PROPOSAL EIGHTY
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. AND
WE ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE ALLEY-
DOCUMENTATION ABOUT A WORK WORK
TO HELP BUILD A MORE WILL NEED
AT THE TIME OF MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AT WITH THE INFANT WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT COMMENT FROM THE LINE
TWENTY NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ERIN APT WITHOUT ADVOCATE
WE APPRECIATE THE VARIOUS
BUDGET PER TO. SUPPORT DIDN'T
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUCH HE MUST
ABOUT THE IS THE MESSENGER TO
IT DIDN'T. EXPERIENCE DURING
THE CAN. SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
PART THAT YOU HAD A AND SIXTY
FIVE NINE AFFECT MY TO EXPAND
IT ESTABLISH NEW SCHOOL.
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE SERVER
THINK AREAS AND WE RECKON THAT
GRANTED CONSIDERED DIVERSITY
ABOLISHED GRADE THIRD WE ALSO
BELIEVE THE DEDICATED COMMUNITY
SCHOOL COORDINATOR SHOULD BE A
REQUIRED COMPONENT OF THE
PROGRAM. COURTEENERS FOCUS ON
BUILDING SCHOOL CAPACITY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNITIES AND ARE INTEGRAL TO
THE SUCCESS THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL. ADDITIONALLY LONG TERM
COMMUNITY SCHOOL FUNDING IS KEY
WE NEED AT LEAST FOUR TO SIX
YEARS OF COMMITTED FUNDING TO
FULLY PLAN IMPLEMENT AND
EVALUATE PROGRAM IMMEDIATELY
PARTNER WITH STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. WE ALSO SUPPORT
DEDICATED FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND HAVE COMMITTED ADDITIONAL
WRITTEN COMMENTS ON THIS ITEM
LASTLY WE SUPPORT THE TEN
DOLLAR INVESTMENT CLIMATE
SURVEYS THEY ARE NOT THE TO
ALLOCATE STUDENT BOY AND-
STUDENT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AT THE MAKE UP
AS AND HAVE A TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS YEAR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND- COM COMES FROM THE
LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. H.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS ERICA HOFFMAN
WITH THE CAL SCHOOL BOARDS.
BRIEFLY I WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN
MY WITH THE- OF LEGISLATIVE
OFFICE WITH REGARD TO ITEMS AND
DEALING WITH SCHOOL MEDICARE
BILLING- AS PART ONE OF THE
PARTNERS. ON THE SB SEVENTY
FIVE WORK GROUPS THERE IS A LOT
OF DISCUSSION AND I THINK
HAVING THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
WOULD ALSO BE VERY HELPFUL IN
ADDRESSING A NUMBER OF THE
QUESTIONS RAISED WITH REGARDS
TO STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING MORE OF
THE DETAILS. ON THE FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED THERE ARE
VERY OVERLAPPING PROGRAM
THROUGHOUT ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES ABOVE THE COUNTY
LEVEL THE SCHOOLS LEVEL AND WE
DO NEED TO GET A MUCH BETTER
HANDLE ON THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE IN THE
FUTURE. YEAH THANK YOU.
ENTERNEXT PUBLIC COMMENT COMES
FROM THE LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR MIKE ITSELF. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. I APOLOGIZE THERE SEEMS
TO BE NO ONE THERE- MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
PEOPLE WISHING TO COMMENT OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT AND WITH THAT WE WILL
ADJOURN.